[Music]
human technopol is created to carry out
and to enable
research into human biology
and we hope by doing this will
contribute to human health and human
well-being
crayon is a structural biology technique
i would say is the structural biology
technique at the moment it helps
explaining how cell works our protein
and macromolecular machine ultimately
fuel the cells
without knowing the shape and the form
and how does this macromolecular machine
works we do not understand how our life
works
[Music]
at human technical we had to build
everything from scratch and for us our
key priority was to establish a network
of instruments that were like integrated
to each other
so that we could perform from plastic
sections to high resolution single
particle application going through
in-situ and cryo-electron tomography
and that's why we opted for the
thermoscientific package
human technopol is building up fantastic
facilities not only for the electron
microscope but also light microscopy we
will have an organoid facility and a
genomic
facility so plenty of possibilities on
how to expand our research avenues and
one thing that is clearly important for
us is to be able to
provide a range of you know
understanding structural function
instead of like creating barriers we are
really trying to maximize the
interactions between scientists work in
very different field but ultimately we
want to answer biological question of
such a breath that only by maximizing
this interaction we can really take on
that and i think this is quite a unique
opportunity to start something from
scratch like this where these
disciplines which are very
technology-based come actually together
instead of being separated in
compartments
the two major benefits from macquariem
experiment are
the fast response
and the level of details by which we can
really answer our scientific questions
like for example studying viruses or
studying protein damage misfunction
inside the cell
ultimately we depend on basic
discoveries that do not come from
structural biology per se but from
geneticists molecular biologists etc so
this is also an infrastructure that
should be open to the italian community
and who knows maybe to the entire south
european community if needed to be
it is in the interest of structural
biologists to make the field triumph as
accessible as possible to the water life
sciences community
[Music]
welcome to our 2021 lab roots series my
name is leah lavery marketing manager
for life science electron microscopy
thermo fisher scientific and your
moderator today
this is the ninth webinar in our series
and we welcome back any returning
attendees
and a big hello to new attendees
wherever you are in the world
i hope you enjoyed the video of the
researchers at human technical in milan
italy our speaker today gaia pankino is
from the human technical gaia is the
associate head of structural biology
research center
gaia's presentation is titled towards a
mechanistic understanding of motile and
primary celia with clem cryo-electron
tomography and expansion microscopy we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
now let me introduce today's speaker
guys ingino is the associate head of
center for structural biology at human
technical in milan italy her team
operates right at the interface between
structural and molecular cell biology
using the latest methodologies from both
fields to study the molecular machines
required for the assembly and function
of motile and primary cilia she received
her phd in evolutionary biology from the
university of siena italy
in 2007 for her studies of
bio-indicators for contaminated soils
em quickly became central in her
research after a short postdoc in the em
lab of the university of siena she moved
to switzerland where she worked at the
eth zurich and the paul share institute
to investigate the structure of ciliary
components using cryon
in 2012 dr pangino became a research
group leader at the max planck institute
of molecular cell biology and genetics
in dresden germany from where she
recently moved to the human technical in
milan
gaia thank you very much for joining us
and please begin your presentation
hi everybody thank you very much leah
for the very kind introduction my name
is gaia fujino i am the associate head
of the center for structural biology of
the human technopol
at the human technopol we want to
understand the molecular mechanism of
cellular processes that are important
for human health and disease
we do that by generating a continuum of
functional and structural information
from understanding the defects at the
genetic level to understanding the
phenotype of the pathology of the human
pathology
in my lab we do that by using a
structural cellular biology approach
which means that we use cellular
structural uh biology classical
structural biology approach such as 5am
combined with
methods and technologies that come from
cellular biology i will give you some
examples of how we do that during the
presentation
so my lab focus on the biology of cilia
and eukaryotic flagella
these are elongated organs that descend
from the cell bodies of most eukaryotic
cells ranging from single cell organisms
to cells in complex tissues in our
bodies
on the left here you see a phamidoma
cell swimming using these two long cilia
also called flagella this is a green
algae that moves in the direction of the
light in order to do photosynthesis
using the two flagella
now cilia have important motility
function obviously but beside the
motility function they have all the
fundamental signaling sensing functions
in many organs in our bodies defects in
the assembly and the function of motile
and primary cilia generate a large
number of devastating human pathologies
that are collectively called
ciliopathies
here a very simple example of
faciliopathies is known as primary
serial dyskinesia you might know that in
our lungs we have cells that produce
mucus that is important for trapping
viruses bacteria and
dust in our lungs and then there are
cells that are affiliated and the
seizure of this cells that beats in
asynchronous ways and in this way move
the mucus that is dirty out of the out
of our lungs
obviously the effects in the atom then
the function the motility function of
the cilia
causes the accumulation of contaminated
mucus in our lungs with chronic
inspections of
chronic infections of our lungs
so fundamental function of cilia for the
human body
now
what is the structure the internal
structure of of a celium or estradiol is
a material
based structure that is known as the
axoneme where we have microtubule
doublets in most cases these microtubule
doublets are organized in a nine-fold
three methyl arrangement here the
microtubule doublets are depicted in
yellow and orange every microtubule
doublet each microtubule doubles is made
of a complete a tubule made of 13
protofilaments of a protein that is
known as tubulin and an incomplete b
tubule that is made of temperature
filaments of tubulin and this and that
grows on top of the ato
beside troubling which is a fundamental
component of every serium of flagellum
proteomic analysis tell us that
mortality contain more than one thousand
six hundred other proteins
this presents
some of them are embedded in the
membrane of the celium that surrounds
the acne but most of them bind to the
mitotic structure and they form in large
complexes and this complexes by in a
very stereotypical way on the mitotic
abstraction
following specific new repeats along the
length of the microtubules such as in
the case of the 24 nanometer repeat of
outer dynamics in charlie molecule most
of them make them the cilium bead
and also um are placed on specific
protofilaments along the microtubule
so this is a very well orchestrated
structure it's a complex structure where
we have more than one 1 600 proteins
however the cell is able to build this
structure the decision in a very short
time in minutes
and we still don't understand how the
structure is assembled also being so
important for human health so this is a
fundamental question that we want to
address in our in my lab
which is how is the cell assembling the
cellular
we know a couple of things we know that
in order to assemble the ceiling we need
a basal body which is a
microtubule-based structure it's also
known as centriole which binds to the
membrane of the cell through
connecting fibers at the eye of the
transition zone
and then the other thing that we know is
that the atoms of the structure happen
at the seniority so the part of the
senior that is growing and progressively
um extending from the cell this is where
the plus end of the microtubules is
found and is also where the microtubule
materials polymerize
now since there is no protein synthesis
in the serum all the components of the
celium are synthesized in the cell body
and then somehow they need to be
transported to the tip of the celium in
order to participate to the ascent
of the organism
in 1993 joel rosenbaum and collaborators
found out that there is a specialized
bi-directional transport system in syria
which is known as intrafragerland
transport or ift
where we have two different type of
motors a plus a microtubule plus
m-directed model known as kinesin tube
which moves components of the celium
from the cell body to the tip of the
cellulum and the dynamic muscle which is
a microtubule minus hand directed muscle
which moves the machinery
after unloading the cargoes at the tip
of the celium back to the cell body
now the interaction between these
muscles and the different carbons all
the different proteins that compound
compost the celium
is not mediated by a vesicular transport
but
by two large
complexes of ift adapter proteins which
are known as iftb with 16 proteins and
ifta with six proteins
we know that these proteins from uh room
temperature electron microscopy we know
that these proteins form large
assemblies in the ceiling
which were defined as ift trains
enter great ift trends move cargo from
the cell body to the tip then the
machinery unloads the cargos is
reorganized and retrograde ift trains
move with the danube model back to the
cell board
we know quite a lot about the genetics
of this system we know that even
mutation for even a single component can
cause devastating effect on the function
of the transport and assembly of the
celium on the function of cilia and
therefore cause serious
however there are a lot of aspects of
how this machinery
works that are still not known at the
mechanistic level so in my lab we
investigate the infrastructure
introversion and transport the ifc
machinery in order to understand how it
works
if we take one of the ift proteins with
a fluorescently fluorescent uh exo a gfp
for example and we put a chlamydomonas
set on the glass slide and then we use
total internal reflection fluorescent
microscopy turf microscopy we can look
at the dynamics of these strains they
move
up and down the syria in uh old flagella
of acrominoganas
and this is exactly what happens also in
cilia and flagella in our body okay so
the first thing that we see is that this
is a very fast transport system where
the trains can move up to four microns
per second
and you can see the trains zipping up
and down the sea the two ceilings here
the other thing that we can notice is
that we have more than 20 trains zipping
up and down the ceiling in a given time
despite the fact that there is a limited
space there because you might remember
from what i showed you before that there
are only nine microtubule tablets
present in the celium and we also know
that this um ifc train to move in the
space in the limited space between the
membrane and the microtubules
so we were puzzled by the fact that
despite the neurospace and the fact that
there are many veins dipping up and down
the scene at a given time we never see
collisions between trains that move in
opposite directions between enterograms
of restraint
so we thought how do we address this
question there must be a mechanism that
regulates the logistics of this
transport system in the cilium but what
is this mechanism
um in order to address this question we
thought we can use electron microscopy
because in electron microscopy we can
investigate the intimate relationship
between each single strain and each
single microtubule doublets of the
acronym as you can see here in the image
where we spot a train
in the associated with one microtubule
so that we can define we can
figure out if for example there are
microtubules tablets that are specific
for different directions of transport
or if trains are instead able to jump
from one microtubule to another
microscope before conditions would
happen
however this is a fixed sample
where we cannot know if this is an
integrated or a retrofit
so in order to bring dynamic information
into the em resolution images
we have to develop a method of
correlating microscopy that was a time
resolved method that would allow us to
bring information about the
directionality of the train from turf
microscopy to the aem microscope
this is how the method works
we
it's a millisecond time result for
relative microscopy approach because the
trains are so fast that whatever other
method was available at that time would
not be fast enough to do correlating
microscopy to catch these strains
so practically we start with imaging
after amino monocels in turn microscopy
here we are going to focus on one
specific flagellum
you will see here as soon as i start the
movie that the trains zip up and down
this flagellum then i'm gonna plot space
over time
and you will see how the at each single
train that is moving will leave a trace
in the camograph that will be generated
and depending on the the direction of
movement you will see different diagonal
direction in the camograph and this will
represent the different directionality
of the train so and just start the movie
trains zip up and down and roger trains
they move from the base
go to the tip leave
a trace in this direction retrograde
trains in the other direction as you can
see here
and then you see that at this point in
time
all the trends all the traces of the
trends become vertical this is because
we introduce a fixative in the flow
chamber where we are imaging the cells
and by doing so we fix we stop in place
every single train
so now we have material that we can use
for electron microscopy for which we
need to fix the sample in order to be
able to then prepare it for the em and
image it inside an electron microscope
however since we have a recording of
whatever before we use the fixative we
can go back in time and define for each
single train what was the directionality
of movement if it was an anthropogenic
plane or a reticulate stream we can do
it just manually like i show it here or
we can do a bit more sophisticated where
we take the tamograph we make a free
transform
and we mask different species of
different transforms that correspond to
the different diagonals
and then by choosing one space in the
fourier transform and
making a battery transform we get we can
at this point select
uh retrograde or enterography trends in
this case entropy strains
so we can color code each single spot
based on the directionality of movement
now don't forget that this same cell
that we were imaging in curved
microscopy is fixed on the glass slide
so we can prepare this sample for
electron microscopy we need to stain it
we embed it and then we take the
embedding there is an embedding we
section this material in order to obtain
uh sections that contain the complete
flagellum
and then we can take images along the
length of the flagellum in order to
reference to reconstruct the complete
length of the flagellum of course we
don't do this just with 2d images but we
use tomography that allowed us to
reconstruct a 3d volume of the complete
serum so what is tomography is a simple
concept we insert our sample on an em
grid inside the electron microscope
transmission electron microscope and we
acquire images while we tilted the
sample
by doing that we obtain
images of the same object from different
viewpoints that we can then use by
computationally making back projections
and generating a 3d volume atomograms
that represents our object of interest
in this in case a segment of the
plagiarism
so by doing so we were able to
reconstruct the complete
volume the complete tomogram of an
entire flagellum the one that we were
imaging in turf microscopy we look for
all the electron density that correspond
to ift trains we correlate the position
of this electron density with the
information we have from the fluorescent
microscopy and in this way for each
single string we were able to know the
position to which microsoft would double
its optimization doublets of the action
name the train was associated
their morphology and also if this was an
enterograph or a retrograde string
by using this approach we discover a
number of things first of all we know
now that the entropy trends and
retrograde trains have a different
morphology different repeats of the
particles which means that they undergo
a complete restructuring at the tip of
the ceiling where they switch from the
mechanism driven motility to the dynamic
motility the other thing that we learned
is that there are no microtubule
doublets that are specific for entropy
or retrograde streams practically all
the nine microtubules doublets of the
celium
can be used by both enterovirus and
retrograde strains however
a deep
inspection of our data also showed that
all the entropy trends move associated
to the b tuber of each microtubule
dialect the incomplete tubule
while the res the retrograde strength
that are the ones that are moved by
dynamic motors
move along the a tube the complete
microtubule of each method without it
so using this trick this timer
millisecond time result for relative
approach we were able to bring the
dynamic information that we had from
turf microscopy to informational
electron microscopy resolution and
discover that the two microtubules of
each microtubule doublet in the
actioning are functionally different for
the ist machining where canadian models
like to walk along the ato board and
dynamic motors selectively walk along
the sorry they can't remove along the b
tube or endangering muscles along the a
tube
in this way we understood two
fundamental aspects of celia biology
first of all why do we have microtubule
doublets in cilia this structure this
microtubule structure are present
exclusively in cilia so we give here
a possible explanation of why we have
multiple tablets in order to serve this
special segregation of the ift motility
and also we explain how it is possible
that we have so many planes dipping up
and down the ceiling without the
collisions happen uh inside the ceiling
so that the transport can can smoothly
happen and in a very regular way
okay
so uh why uh carnesian and daniel motors
select one c one microsoft instead of
the other uh still not known we are
investigating the possible role of
tubulin phosphorylational modification
in defining the specificity of these
microtubules for the different models
now
let's move to another story still
relating to the ifc machinery you can
see here that the structure of the
celium is actually the real structure of
the film because the densities that you
see of the acronym come from high
electron microscopy you will see later
how this is possible however the
structure of between it's a very
let's say artistic interpretation of
this kind of data they come from
transmission electron microscopy but
transmission electron microscopy are
samples that have been fixed with
chemical fixation
dehydrated stain with heavy metals and
so on so not the best uh technique in
order to understand the molecular
structure of these strains
so if you want to understand the whole
the how all the different components
complex p complex a and the models of
the ift machinery and maybe even the
cargos come together in order to form
the trains functional trends in the
sydney we have to move to a different
technology and techniques
so this can be achieved using
cryo-electron tomography and subtomogram
energy here you will see a movie where
i'll show you what we do to our
clamidomonas cells
that we use as a model system to
investigate ift you might might have
realized at this point
in order to perform high electron
tomorrow we start with happiness women
from the monocells they swim in a drop
of solution on top of honey and grip
and we freeze them very quickly plunge
freeze them
at minus 180 degrees then we insert our
sample on a cryoelectron transmission
microscope and we do tomography as i
said before in tomography we tilt the
sample why we apply images and therefore
we have images from the different views
of the same object that we can use to
reconstruct a model a 3d model of our
celium in this case so atomogram of acid
when we have repetitive structures
inside the tomogram we can extract them
align them and average them in order to
increase the signal to noise ratio of
our structure of interest and if we have
enough particles we can reach very high
resolution
which allowed us to understand how the
how the different molecular components
come together to form large complexes
and cellular machines here we have an
example of a microtubule doublets with a
and the b tube and all the associated
radio spokes and running complexes are
important for the motility of the sea
so we can use the same approach uh to
look at ist here you can see a
characteristic
an example of a tomographic series that
we choose
cryo tm tarzan hello at the max blankie
institute for molecular biology and
genetics investment you see how the
sample is tilted uh
under the microscope and then after that
projection
we can generate autonomous here we are
practically flying to the volume of uh
that represents uh one segment of
acromida monash closure
inspecting these tomograms allowed us to
spot some of the ift trends that are the
um
interesting uh molecular machines we
want to investigate now so this is an
example as you can see my cursor here
and this is another example typically
the trains are placed in between the
microtubule doublets of the celium and
the ciliary membrane
now since we need a taco relative
microscopy before in the study before we
were able also to discriminate in
cryo-em between anterograde strength and
retrograde trends based on the
structural similarities that we had from
the
room temperature electron tomography
from now on uh during the presentation
i'm going to focus on the structure of
the enterograph trends
um
we are making progress on the structure
of the retrograde transfer but we know
more about integrated instruction
so if this lies to one of these strains
here along there we figure out that the
trend is made of three different
subdomains and that these three
different subdomains which we call in
blue green and yellow
form polymers like structures so they
have a specific repeat different repeat
for the different domain
now since these are repetitive
structures we can do what i mentioned
before we can use subtomogram averaging
which means that we extract the sub sub
components that repeat using the
specific um
repeat and we can align and average them
and by doing so we increase the signal
transformation and we were able to
observe for the first time a segment the
3d structure 3d morphology of a segment
of an anterograde ifc train
here you see in the left you see how the
train looks like in a cross view when
you see the cross view of the
microtubule tablet and the membrane uh
represented here and this is a
longitudinal view where we have three
repeats of the polymer the blue polymer
that we indicated before in blue which
has a 18 nanometer repeat
okay so this is a nice blob but it's
still a block how do we go from seeing
this structure
to understanding the molecular
organization of the drain well a trick
that is often used is to look at
different mutants
we have our well-type structure here we
do a proteomic analysis of this
well-type
flagella
or cells we look for all the ift
components they are all there all the
ones that are respected and then we take
amusement for a protein that is called
ift 139 in this case
um
where we know that this is a component
of the is the ifca complex
okay so by removing this protein what's
happening is that all the proteins of
the ifta complex are not able to be
assembled
properly on anterograde trains and
therefore by averaging the structure of
these strains that are depleted of dieta
proteins we can look at where we would
expect the ifta proteins to be placed in
the train because
where we have missing proteins we will
have a missing that
okay and here we go so this area here
that is missing in the mutant correspond
to the ifta
what we discover here is that the ifta
are that are here depicted in yellow now
are practically forming a polymer of 12
nanometers that has a 12 nanometer
repeat that is close to the membrane
this makes a lot of sense because we
know that these adaptor proteins of the
complex a are important for imports in
the celium of
for imports of membrane proteins in the
ceiling
then we go to the next mutant the next
mutant is the donning
is a mutant for the dynamic
now that's a special museum because you
might remember that here we are looking
at anthropology and you might also
remember that enterographeness are moved
by canadian models so why do we look at
the dynamic uh motor on the entryway
thing well dynamic motors cannot move to
the plus end of the microtubules can
move only to the management so it can
only go towards the cell body and not
towards the tip
but they need to be placed at the tip in
order to power reservoir transport so
how do they go to the tip well they need
somehow to be transported and they do it
together with enterovirus
so we expected to find the dynamic motor
as a cargo of the anterior planes
and indeed when we look at the museum
that doesn't have the dynamic muscle we
see that the big chance of the structure
is lost we are depicted in blue so these
are done in muscles and we were psyched
by the fact that these dynamic muscles
also organized into polymers so not
single dynamic muscles are transported
by the trains but entire polymers of
these muscles are concatenated one to
another are moved by anthropography
strength
now i can say onset then the rest of the
structure that is the one depicted in in
green is iftb and iftb
is actually the car uh of the
integration structure has as we will see
later during the presentation will be
confirmed by other studies as well
okay so um
now we know where complex a is
complexity is and also we know a
specialized cargo of the entire
transport which is denied i can tell you
a lot of things about what these
structures tell us for the biology of
ift syrian flagella but i'm gonna focus
on the dynamic model because this is
gonna uh you know give us some
information about a long-standing
question in the biology of syria and
flagella
so here we have this manus and directed
muscle and obviously also the mechanism
of it is a plus interactive model a past
the same tree
now if we look at the other transport
system in the cell
where we have both canadian motor
environments attached to the same
vesicle like in peroxisome transport
what happens is that the motors that
pull in different direction
are engaged in what is known as a tug of
war so they compete for the direction of
movement that makes the particle the
peroxisome
jump up and down along the microtubules
okay this tug of war doesn't exist in
ist
is an extremely processive transport
which means
that mechanism somehow manages to go
from the cell body to the tip of the
ceiling without any uncertainty just
straight okay
so this code for a mechanism that
regulates the activity of the nanomotor
so that there is no competition between
carnegie mendoni during anthropography
transport but how is that achieved
in order to understand how this system
works we look at our tomograms and here
you can see one of these strengths where
we have the three main components that
we identify
if we remove the density of the ifta and
we look at istb and the dynamic models
that are loaded on top of iftb we
discover that the dynamics are loading
on a very specific conformation
which is known as phi conformation or
step conformation in this conformation
the triple earrings
that are the atpase
of the muscle are step one on top of
each other additionally the two legs of
the muscle which we call stocks
are crossed in a conformation that is
very different from what we would expect
from an active donning where the two
legs the two rings are separated and two
legs also separated and free to step
along the microtubule
so this uh cross conformation of phi
conformation where the legs are in uh
crossed
uh was shown to be unable to walk along
microtubules in in these reconstituted
systems so this conformation was found
in purified some
purified samples of dynein muscles from
both the cytoplasm and the flagella and
it was shown that the muscle can bind to
the microtubules but is actually not
able to step along the microphone
so we discover here that the muscle is
loaded in a polymer and in an
autoinhibited conformation
additionally we also noticed that the
motor is loaded on the train in a
special position
so here we rotate our train our model we
put ifta back
and then we see that
the mother domain and the microtubule
binding domain of the muscle
are actually placed away from the muscle
support sandwiched between ifta and isdb
facing the membrane of the ceiling while
the tail of the motor that is something
that is the part of the motor that
usually engages cargos
uh looks in the direction of the
microscope obviously in this position
the muscle cannot even engage the
microtubule to work along it
and therefore we discovered that beside
the authentic conformation we have also
a positional inhibition of the muscle
which is kept and loaded on the train in
a way that the microtubule binding
domain are kept away from the microsoft
but why do we have we need why do we
have two different mechanisms to inhibit
the motility of this of this mode
well somehow we need
to position the muscle away from the
microscope why because it has been shown
that the muscle also init in an
unstabilized conformation can still bind
to the muscles so if we keep the muscle
with the microtubule binding domain
close to the microscope this would
engage the microtubule and somehow slow
down the activity of the kinesin motor
and so the motion to the tip of the seal
so we need to rotate the motor away but
why then we need a conformational
inhibition the motor is already kept
away from the microtubule so we think we
understood why this happens because we
know that when the trains reach the tip
of the ceiling they disassemble and they
actually free dynames at the tip of the
ceiling
so if you can imagine that if a dynamic
is left active and free at the tip of
the cereal hoodie can easily engage on
the microtubules and run back to the
cell body without the ifc machinery on
top while designing what what the
function of the dynamic hypothesis is is
to load on its back the retrograde
trends and bring them back to the cell
body so we expected to find the phy
conformation or the out-inhibited
conformation at the tip of the cellulum
when it is free from from the rest of
the enterograph chain however when we
did tomography or the of the tip of the
ceiling we found out that as soon as the
trains reached the end of the vehicle
they started us disassembling
and the mothers are not found anymore in
this stack conformation of python
formation but the triple earing triple a
plus earrings uh are released from this
file formation as we can see here
so we also found cases when we found
dynamics completely dissociated
constraints where we could see the two
rings separated so what we think is that
at the tip of the serum the muscle goes
from the phi conformation into what is
known as an oven conformation from in
visual studies in this conformation the
motor is not stacked anymore however is
still not able to actively walk along
the microscope so this is a transitional
conformation from the inaudible to the
real active conformation so our
advantages is that the model is then
found in the open conformation at tip of
the serum waiting for a message and
waiting for the rest of your trains to
be assembled
and then all in the in when it is
associated with the rest of the strength
it goes into a active conformation that
can bring the ift machinery back to the
cell body
okay
so now with this study we understood
quite a lot i mean we got the first
model to the first structure of
antarctic trends and in general of the
ift machinery and we understood quite a
lot of the mechanisms that regulate the
dynamos of the integrate transport and
switch at the tip of the ceiling however
we still need to understand what induces
the conversion from enterovirus to
retrograde trends and how the down
inactivity dining motor is activated the
type of scene and what is the factor
that
activates the dynamic mode the other
thing that we are working on is the
structure of the retrograde chain we
know from the
room temperature for relative microscopy
that the structure is pretty different
but we still need to understand how this
conversion happens and what implies in
terms of organizational or the machinery
but i'm gonna go for the next question
which is the following
how are the enterovirus assembled at the
base of the ceiling what is the
mechanism and the process of ift train
assembly at the base of the ceiling even
before the trains are pushed inside the
helium and promote and throttle
transport of serial components
so in order to address this question we
cannot limit our tomography to the area
of the flagella we have to go deep into
the cell
in the area where the the cells the the
cilia are embedded with the bottle body
in the inside the cell body so this area
is much thicker than what we had already
before in the case of of the serious
chlamydomonas of the flagella and if you
look at what we can see in a normal
transmission electron microscopy cryovm
you can see here that
while we can see through the density of
a flagellum in this green square we will
never be able to dis distinguish
anything in this very dark areas
at the base of the signal this is
because the sample there is too thick
and the electrons are not able to go
through in order to generate
an image that we can understand and
interpret so how do we move on what do
we need in order to look at the ift
assembly in the cell body we need a
different technique we need a
cryotherapy bcm a triophotos ion beam
scanning electron microscope this is an
additional microscope which is has been
developed recently and mainly made
available for the scientific community
on in the last years and ferrari is a
very exciting
[Music]
new technology that we can use to look
inside cells
and what happens in this case is that
you you have a cell that is frozen on an
em grip and then you can use a secondary
beam in this case of ions in order to
mill the sample to reduce the thickness
of the sample in specific positions
this will generate what is known as a
vanilla that we can then image in
transmission electron microscopy because
it's thin enough and
of course we want to have this lamella
produce in the area of interest in
ourselves
so uh we have
an additional step in our process now
first we take the cell we freeze the
cells on an angle as we did before with
the camino monastery so you remember
maybe the movie they came in a monster
to swim and then gets frozen quickly on
a neanderthal then first we put this
greeting inside the cryofield acm
where the ion beam is gonna reduce the
thickness and make the lamella and then
the same sample is image in a client
transmission electron microscope and if
we do tomography of course we can
generate also in this case a
three-dimensional representation of our
object of interest
doing so we could we were able to spot
uh so we did this in collaboration with
the uh ben angle's lab and massing
street um where they had access to a uh
carrier pcm
and in this way we were able to spot ift
components of the iot machinery at the
base of the ceiling before they are
inserted into the ceiling and this is uh
um what you can see here is a basel body
and here you can see in the is a
tangential section here the beginning of
the of the ceiling and if we slide
through this volume we find here trains
that are in the process of being
assembled you can see here them they
have a repeating structure also in this
case so this indicates that already
at the level of the cells close to the
base of the serum they machinery
organizing polymers before they get
pushed into the helium
so
what we learned from this kind of
imaging
is that ift trains
are already assembling as polymeric
structure
even before they are pushed into the
ceiling or they move into the ceiling
and you can see here these elongated
structure that are hanging away distant
from the microtubule tablets practically
hanging in the in the cytoplasm of the
cell
we learn from these structures that and
so we were able to
use a subtomogram averaging approach
also in this case the same we did
similar approach to what we did for
mature ift trends in the in the cilium
and by doing subtomogram averaging
looking at the similarity between the
two structure we were able to identify
again the position of istb here depicted
in yellow ifta depicted in orange and
the dynamium motor in pink
okay so we learn uh from from dependent
from the ability to reconstruct the
structure we learned that the complexes
already before they entered the theorem
have a similar morphology to what we
find in antarctic enterography trends
that are already inside the cellium one
thing that we notice is that there is an
additional density
here in iftb uh of immature or
assembling trends that we don't find in
the mature trains inside the ceiling so
this area here this density here could
be something that is related to the
um
ascending assembly factor for the ift
machinery or something that keeps the
imc machinery uh stopped at the base of
the ceiling and that um
maybe is released only when the chinese
muscle needs to be activated
okay so another thing that we learned is
that ifgb that is here depicted in
yellow is actually the polymer the
distance the most out of the cellium
down in the cytoplasm therefore it seems
to
this seems to indicate the iftb is
actually the car of the train
assembly and is the first thing that is
assembled and then all the rest comes on
top of iftb uh first of all
well one part of the machinery that we
could not
image or
recognize in our structure
in both assembling trains and mature
trains is the canadian model however we
know the mechanism model is fundamental
for the motivity of the trains so we
wanted to understand where the cannabis
motor is integrated in the structure and
also in general what is the process of
assembly of these strengths
in order to do so we combine our criem
approach with another approach that is
typical of the cell biology field that
is expansion microscopy and in this case
ultra-structural expansion microscopy
that was developed in the lab of
virginia hamilton emporia
expansion microscopy is a technique
where the sample is cross-linked with a
hydrogen you have here an example of
microsoft of course you can do it within
paris
and the hydrogen is a
material that when it is in presence of
a liquid environment expansive cells so
if the sample is cross linked with a
hydrogel in the moment in which you do
expansion
the complete sample and not only the gel
will expand with it
then once this function is done we can
use antibodies for specific structure of
the cell for example microtubules or for
example components of the ifc machinery
and since the sample is expanded these
antibodies easily find the antigen they
have to bind to
once the immunolabeling is performed
we can then
add the fluorophore and use this to
image our samples in
our expanded samples in confocal
microscopy
so this allowed us to have very little
fluorescent microscopy images of the
microtubular system of akamidomonas and
of the ift system
you can see here that we can even
discriminate the nine microtubules
triplets of a centriole of the basal
body
at the base of the empathy
here another example of this is
functional microscopy the cool thing of
this expansion microscopy is that we can
reach the super resolution
we can practically perform imaging that
is better than super resolution uh in a
normal confocal microscope
and we can even
correlate the information that we have
from the suspension microscopy with the
information that we learned using a
cryo-electron tomorrow approach here you
can see this is not exactly the same
sample but you can see how the
information that we get about the
position of the microtubules of the
basal body end of the acronym and the
position of the trains corresponds very
well to what you would expect in a uh
image that comes from a tri-electron
thomas
okay by doing so we were able and we
what we did is that we used different
antibodies for different components of
the ist machinery to look at the
relative positioning of these components
at the base of the ceiling
and by doing so we could identify the
position of ifta iftb
they're done in water and also the
canadian model and we learned the
following thing we learned that
there is a hierarchical
process of ift train assembly where the
ift b complexes
are the ones that organize into polymers
already far away from the structure of
the ceiling then the second component
that is integrated in the structure is
ista
the third component is integrated on the
structure is the dynamic model and all
these organizing two polymers and then
the third component is the carnesian
model so the kinesin muscle is
integrated in the structure only in the
area where the planes are already
associated with the robot and are
practically ready to be pushed into the
city
okay so here another an example on how
you combine
expansion microscopy with triumph to
learn more about the ift machinery
and now i'm going to talk about i i'm
going to stop talking about ist and i
would like to switch to a different
topic
until now in my presentation uh you have
seen
work that has been done on a special
model system that is largely used to
investigate celia biology which is
camino monas
so
green algae they are important as a
model system model organisms uh however
we don't have only motile cilia
like from the mona has in our bodies
but our body
in several organs in our bodies we have
another type of syria that is also very
important these are philadelphia
motility function
but have fundamental signal and sensing
function and uh you know they have very
important role for the function of our
organs they are called primary
studying primary here is difficult it's
more difficult because they are embedded
in complex tissues they don't detach
very easily from the cell and therefore
it's not easy to extract them in order
to
see them in electron microscopy and even
do biochemistry so we know we knew very
little about the structure and the
compositional composition of privacy
however
in the textbook
what we know about primary cellular
structure is summarized as follow while
in
motile cilia we have a very very complex
axon when nine microsoft would double
it's too much level at the center and
the number of proteins i said the 1600
proteins that bind to this structure in
order to allow the motility of the
celium
primary celia are usually considered a
very simplified version of this
um symmetrical structural mutation so
mortality are defined as nine plus two
because they have nine marketable
doublet so two methods below the center
while primaries here are defined as nine
plus zero because they are expected to
have nine modulus without between this
symmetrical arrangement and
not much at the center of the action
so in my lab with the divisor
to purify primary helium from
cells that come from the kidney
now primary silica in the kidney are
fundamental for the function of the
kidney because they evaluate the quality
of the urine filtrate and go to the flow
of the urine if primary celia in the
kidney don't work properly we have
cell proliferation and formation of
cysts in the kidney and therefore a
pathology that is known as primary
errors or polycystic kidney disease
now we devise a
method to
take a primary celia and prepare them
from cryo-electron microscopy then
perform electron tomography as i
explained before by doing so we learn a
number of things about primary figures
that were not known before the first
thing is that the nine plus two
arrangement of microtubule tablets in
the primary theorem is actually not
there
so comparison between the structure of
homozygous and the family recipient
shows that they might
double to already right at the base of
the helium migrates towards the center
of the of of the accident breaking this
mind for symmetrical arrangement and
that very soon micros
and we have only microtubule singlets so
a tubules that also migrate towards the
center of the structure and the ends are
different distances from the tip so that
we have a very slender tip of the time
and team
then we also learned
that um contrary to what we find in
primary immortal celia where the
microtubules are therefore heavily
decorated with a number of proteins that
are known as microtubule internal
proteins or mips
that strengthen the microtubules and so
that they are very
stable and resistant
in primary celia we have maturable
internal proteins but they they are
really limited in number and definitely
don't have a beautiful beautiful
periodical arrangement as this is found
in motile syria
so this is another difference between
the two systems then seeing that there
are not many massive
internal proteins meet proteins in
primary syria we were puzzled about the
mechanism that stabilizes primary cilia
in
sorry destabilizes microcuboids in
primary syria so we had a look at the
better look at the
structure of microtubules and we found
out that there is a protein
that decorates the external surface
of the microtubules of primary celium
all along the length of the primary
serum by subtomogram averaging we were
able to resolve the structure of this
product and discover that it binds
it is located in between product tubulin
protofilaments with the exception of the
seam of the multitude
by fluorescent microscopy
we discovered that this protein is eb1
eb1 is a protein that is normally found
in the cell
positioned at the plus end of the
multitude and so we were really
surprised to find out that on the
contrary in primary celia eb1 is found
all along the length of the microscope
along the axon
okay next thing that we discovered is
that we have actin filaments in primary
series actin filaments are not found in
mossad celia however proteomic analysis
showed for a long time that there are a
number of acne regulating proteins found
by proteomic analysis inflammation
but african filaments were never
visualized in primary syria so it's only
two cryo-electron microscopical electron
tomography that we could finally
verify or discover that we have actin
organizing in in filaments
inside the primary ceiling we can find
them associated with the membrane or
intercalated between the mitochondria
and we confirmed this localization that
we could
observe by tri-electron tomography using
fluorescence microscopy approach also in
this case
okay so a number of things uh were
revealed using high electron tomography
uh about the biology of tamarisillia we
were in this case even able to identify
new scenario components that were not
identified with other technologies uh
before
this is the case of primary cedar that
come from kidneys and from md security
cells but as i mentioned before a lot of
different organs in our body contains
different types of primary celia and we
know very little about their structure
and their
protein composition so in the future we
want to investigate the structure and
the composition and eventually the
function of primary cilia from different
organs also using new technology
that
could be very helpful for preparing
organoids from the different
cells reproducing different organs
last thing that i want to tell you
is that i promise at the beginning of
this presentation that what we want to
do is to use a structural cellular
biology approach to investigate
molecular processes in the cells that
are important for human health and
well-being now i don't have time to go
through a completely different study but
this is a paper that we published very
recently in collaboration with casting
yankees lab and it is about the
identification
of a
mutation that affects the um placing on
the microtubules of a specific tubulin
postulation modifications that is called
the isolation
now when we have this mutation
glycolation is not present anymore on
the microtubules
of the celium it turns out that then we
have this mutation
we have male infertility so the sperms
are not able to swim properly towards
the
excess and therefore
contributes to the fertilization
now we look at sperm cells they come
from
mutants
for this particular
enzyme
and we found out that these sperm cells
are unable to swim along a straight line
on the contrary they spin in circles
that's why on the science cover that's
called spinning sperms
we wanted of course to understand that
the molecular mechanism of what happens
here and also in this case as i
explained now a number of times along
the presentation we use a cryotomography
approach entire and subtomogram
averaging approach and this allowed us
to discover that there are no defects in
the assembly of the structure of the
celium however
we uh we've we discovered that
the mozart that are responsible for the
building of the celium are affected
therefore formation is affected so that
the beating of the cinnamon is altered
the sperms can still beat but they they
swinging circle instead of going
straight
so i hope with this presentation to have
shown to you a number of examples where
we use a combination of cryogen with
with
methods from cell biology that allowed
us to investigate cellular process even
dynamic cellular processing in the cells
using tri-electron microscopy
and with this i want to thank you for
the attention and i want to thank all
the uh
members of my lab of my team
there are many the studies that you saw
today uh were made by uh performed by um
ludwig stepanek for the podesta
microscopy malaika jordan and daniel's
dinner for
for the structural analysis of the base
of the system in collaboration with
uh paul gishar virginia
and gonzalo and performed the cardio
electron microscopy of primary celia and
gonzalo also participated uh to the to
the work of this
friends finnish firms so with this i
hope i acknowledge all the members of my
lab so uh thank also to also animal lab
and vladimir valkalab for the
collaboration of the family student
paper and then i clearly have to thank
all the microscopy facilities and the
other facilities here the max plant
institute for molecular biology genetics
i'm now at the human technical where we
have amazing electromicroscopy
facilities with tools that i never could
use before so i'm looking forward to to
use them for more studies but most of
the words that you have seen here were
done at the max point institute in
destin and then the fantastic electron
microscopy facility like microscopic
acidity and dimensionality these touch
diseases are the human technical thank
you so much for your attention and i
hope there is still a bit of time for
questions
okay thank you very much gaia for that
presentation looks at like many of you
have submitted
questions already um if you do have a
question please type them into ask the
question box and click send
so we'll start with the first question
can you please comment on the ideal
fluorophores that can be used for clen
is gfp too big
hi um i hope you can hear me well yes
okay
uh first of all i forgot to thank you
guys
thank you for inviting me
to this webinar it's really nice and so
thank you very much
um
clem yes so ideal floral force it really
depends on the type of correlative
microscopy you want to do
what i show today
is correlative microscopy approach where
we were looking at dynamic processes so
we use gfp in this case because we
wanted to do
you know some fluorophore that is not so
bright because we wanted to a sort of a
single molecule tracking of these ift
trends we have many proteins repeating
in the train so they didn't want to have
very strong fluorescence there however
uh
so we were looking at a live
sample and then we fix it briefly with
the glutaraldehyde and we stop the
imaging just after fixation okay so
um jeffy is perfectly fine in that case
however if you want to do for example um
imaging uh in florescent microscopy
after you fix the sample
and maybe you want to even image
the the sample after you embed the
sample in resin you cannot really rely
on gfp it's not so good there are other
floral for other
florescent proteins like m
[Music]
eos em that have been developed
in order to be able to resist the osmium
staining and the embedding in resin like
even embedding and this is
been developed recently so this is a
very good choice if you want to look if
you want to do correlative microscopy on
a plastic embedded sample where you want
to image the fluorescence when the
sample is already embedded
if you want to do correlative
cryo cryoglam for example you might want
to choose something that is brighter
than gfp
for example m cherry
or i know that something that is called
like m wasabi was recently shown to have
good performances
in this case uh also for um
raising
embedded samples actually
um
one thing that maybe
we should be aware of uh
in terms of correlating microscopy and
decision for
gfp for fluorescent protein is the fact
that some fluorescent protein
tend to polymerize
and so if you are looking
at what you expect to be
so if you're looking at something that
you don't know exactly how it looks like
in the cell but you want to find the
true of a relative approach and then
suddenly you find out that
it makes a filament it makes a polymer
just verify that this is actually
happening also in the absence of the
fluorescent protein for example gfp
tends to
bind together to polymerize
okay yep thank you for the answer i'll
move on to the next question um so
fascinating insights into interpersonal
transport how thin do your lamellae
samples need to be so that you can
examine them with sufficient resolution
okay so i didn't do the
the fibbing but i believe that the
thickness that is targeted in this case
is about 300 nanometers
or a bit more than 300 nanometers i
think this is the best
thickness in order to to have very
crispy images in in cardiothomography
okay
uh thanks uh next question there are
various types of uh cilopathies is there
a way to examine tissue cells from such
pathological samples using cryo-em and
what would be needed for this can such
samples be high pressure frozen yeah
well
of course the uh the ultimate goal is to
look at you know this kind of processes
in cells so they come from from patients
for example
or
yeah that's a confrontation so we can do
the things we can take the cells and
culture them and then use a plunge
freezing approach of cells that are
grown directly on grits and
and then if we look at celia for example
that have protrude outside of the cell
so they might be this part of the cell
might be thin enough to be image
directly in transmission electron
microscopy but in most of the cases i
think we have to go through cryofee bcm
approach
and then imaging in tomography after
that
for um
then if you want to image secret samples
we can do that too now
we can take small biopsies from patients
and then we can use a high pressure
freezing approach and then
use
a technique that is called liftout
that
allows us to practically cut in the
cryofib acm
a piece of the of the sample that is
frozen and to a micro manipulator that
is inside a microscope we can take this
part put it in a new grid and so
like a big lamella we can be taken out
of the sample that is too thick
otherwise to be uh manipulated we can
put this
section on another grid and then perform
uh
produce a lamella on that part of the
sample
and the other interesting thing is to
actually produce organoids
from cells that come from patients and
so this would be something in between
you know cells and biopsies
looking at organoids
okay thank you
unrelated to ift trains and cilia a more
general question towards tomography
is it possible to also obtain images of
uh for example an atp
eps in the cellular context
yes it is
um
[Music]
so
let's say in general
silent flagella are very nice uh samples
to perform kind of electron tomography
and subtomogram averaging in particular
because things tend to organize along
the microtubules so
it's very easy let's say like this i
don't want to upset the people that work
on silent flavella but it's definitely
easier in flagella to spot the position
of the protein complexes you want to
investigate if they bind along the
microtubules they have a repetitive
structure you can just
pick along the microtubules with a
certain specific periodicity and then
you have a number of particles that you
can analyze by photogrammetry now ift is
a bit more complicated because these are
trains that are you know short
relatively short and only in certain
position in the ceiling so it took much
longer to find them but still they have
a repeating structure
when you don't have that it becomes more
difficult so you often try electron
tomography and subtomogram averaging
is done on things that have a specific
repeat or that are very abundant in in
cells like dragon
however tomography is getting more and
more images in tomography are getting
more and more i was
getting crispier
and also thanks to
you know image analysis techniques
techniques that are being developed at
the moment like denoising technologies
with neural networks for example like an
example is cryocare and so these allowed
us to see better inside the images that
we can obtain by september by
cryo-electron tomography and also spot
proteins and particles that are present
in a limited number
okay thank you um move on to the next
question
you mentioned that it's not clear what
determines binding of the motors to a
particular a or b tubulin
what role do small microtubule binding
proteins or phosphorylations play
okay yes so this is about the dining and
mechanism model binding to the what did
i say first the a tubular and the b
tubule of the microtubule tablet
and
we don't know exactly how that that is
done there are different ideas uh about
what could contribute to this
uh one possibility as i said is the fact
that
a tubal and b tube will bear different
tubulin post-relational modifications
that are changes in the sequence of the
tubulin
specific to a or b tubule that are
induced by
specific enzymes
and
this has been shown in the past and now
we are confirming that with different
approach including cryo electron to
monitor something that we didn't publish
yet but we hope we can publish soon
um so we are investigating that
possibility of course there are other
things like for example
the
the
the structure of the muscle supports
they have the same losses but they have
a different curvature maybe the muscles
could sense that the other possibilities
that there are indeed
the the multiple doublets of the cilium
are heavily decorated with with proteins
including microtubule internal proteins
that form very specific they are long
very specific protofilaments of the two
different microtubules
and in the past we thought that these
proteins i mean we still believe that
these proteins are important for
stabilizing the specific curvature of
the microtubule and making them strong
enough to withstand the the missing of
the serum however we now know thanks to
single particle analysis
reconstructions and analysis
models
of the microtubules that we have a high
resolution structures now and we know
that this protein is stand from the
lumen optimizers over on the surface of
the microtubule in certain cases so may
they might also
interact with the microbial binding
domain of the mother and influence their
behavior
okay thank you i think this will be our
last question for today
so can expansion microscopy use to image
membrane-bound proteins and membrane
structures
okay i don't have experience with that
but i don't see why not might be you
know
maybe somebody that is
you're gonna shoot me now but no i don't
say why not because uh you know
when you apply expansion microscopy your
sample in need complexity is fun
so as a
isotropic expansion so if you have good
antibodies for a certain membrane
protein there should be no reason why
you should not be able to
to localize
this membrane protein using an expansion
microscopy approach
okay thank you well thank you guy again
for your talk today and before we go i'd
like to also thank the audience for
joining us and for your many interesting
questions
questions we do not have time for today
will be addressed via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
i want to let the audience know that
this webcast and others in our electron
microscopy series can be viewed on
demand on lab routes
you can also register for upcoming
sessions and we encourage you to share
this session with your colleagues who
have made missed the event today
if you still need more cryotomography in
your day please visit
thermofisher.com
forward slash cryotomography the address
you see there
you can download for example our
selected publication ebook or contact us
here if you have any additional
questions thank you again very much gaia
for your talk today and your time and
especially to all of you for joining us
today until next time goodbye
thank you bye